par l'homme que vous évoquiez jérémy le
député sortant jean marie sermier vous
êtes donc candidat des républicains
député maire de dole et on le répète
vous briguer un quatrième mandat à
l'assemblée nationale face à vous il ya
notamment stéphane montre les monsieur
vous êtes maire de rang vous êtes
également conseiller régional et vous
êtes candidat dans cette législative
pour le front national
sur ce plateau pour débattre avec nous
également paul-henri barre alors vous
monsieur vous êtes issu des rangs du
modem vous êtes candidat investi par à
la république en marche
vous êtes quand même connu sur la place
publique un si j'ose dire puisque vous
êtes secrétaire général de la capeb la
confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment dont le
jura en face eh bien nous avons jean
marc jean bernard parent dans
jean-bernard marque easy candidat de la
france un soumises à ce jour vous n'avez
pas de mandat on signale quand même que
vous avez été candidat aux européennes
c'était en 2015 sous l'étiquette de
nouvelles donnes 2014 à 2014 pardon et
madame laurence bernier c'est la femme
de ce débat candidate fit parti
communiste mais moi je ne débat pas
j'arbitre avec vers les rémy candidate
et donc du parti communiste avec le
soutien celle des même cas de figure sur
les trois circonscriptions du jura on le
rappelle avec le soutien du parti
socialiste et d'europe écologie les
verts madame vous êtes maire de frasne
les meulières je précise que sont
également candidat dans cette
circonscription
véronique henry ali kurt dominique revoy
et sylvie viard on va commencer avec une
question avec avec jean marie sermier
lorsque vous avez briguer avec succès la
municipalité de dole vous aviez expliqué
que vous seriez prêt à ne pas vous
représenter à un mandat de député pour
conserver votre fauteuil de maire vous
êtes soumis comme chacun à la loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats aujourd'hui vous
voilà à nouveau candidat à la députation
pourquoi ce revirement
d'abord je voudrais avoir une petite
pensée pour nos amis anglais qui ont
connu un attentat encore cette nuit et
puis je pense que la ville de dole tout
à l'heure on aura donc les victimes
parce que je pense que c'est j'imagine
la solidarité commune qui doit nous unir
alors pourquoi je suis candidat
simplement parce que je pense que nos
territoires ont besoin de candidats
solides
je pense que nos territoires ont besoin
de candidats qui sont en proximité et
je pense que la ruralité a un avenir en
france un pays je laime mon pays c'est
la france et la france a besoin d'une
ruralité forte et je pense que je suis
en capacité de porter cette voie de la
réalité de nos territoires de l'ensemble
des communes de notre secteur pour que
le député puisse s'exprimer
ou non de tous à l'assemblée nationale
je vous ai dû filer contraindre la
presse écrite disant aussi en substance
face au score énorme du front national
je serai l'homme de la situation
vous estimez être en capacité de barrer
la route à la rague front national qu'on
a connues notamment lors de la dernière
présidentielle
je suis candidat pour l'ensemble de la
circonscription
je suis candidat pour le rassemblement
le rassemblement de toutes celles et
ceux qui veulent faire avancer notre
pays qui veulent faire en sorte que des
lois utile soit voté pour notre pays
et quand la loi n'est pas utile pour
notre pays qu'elle ne soit pas votée
tout simplement
donc ma proximité et fait que je peux
connaître un certain nombre de personnes
qui me disent tous les jours ce qu'il ne
ressente au quotidien la difficulté de
trouver du travail
la difficulté de la sécurité c'est la
sécurité on en a beaucoup parlé mais
aujourd'hui elle revient au premier plan
avec les problèmes internationaux les
problèmes nationaux et je crois que
outre les discours il ya aussi les actes
et sur la ville de dole mais on a fait
un certain nombre d'actions qui sont
extrêmement précises par exemple armée
la police municipale par exemple mettre
en place une vidéo protection
et bien moi à l'assemblée nationale je
porte ce discours pour que nous
puissions permettre à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens d'être en grande sécurité
parce que la sécurité c'est ce que nous
devons aux plus faibles d'entre nous si
vous êtes élu à nouveau député vous
serez contraint de passer la main à la
mairie de dole à qui je serai dans la le
conseil municipal de dole évidemment je
reste au conseil municipal de dole j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire à tous les
maires et puis évidemment majorité la
majorité municipale se réunira pour
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent au
moment où cela s'impose donc et quand
les cas qu'ils sachent en tous les cas
que je reste très mobilisée le savent
les dolois parce que la ville bouge
depuis trois ans la ville rayonne depuis
trois ans et donc cette ville elle a
besoin effectivement d'une énergie avec
un député dans les rangs de sa majorité
allez un autre maire mais d'une plus
petite commune stéphane
montrelais vous êtes conseiller régional
vous étiez aussi candidat au
départemental en 2015
vous êtes candidat cette fois aux
législatives vous êtes candidat à tous
les mandats
ça c'est une bonne question
effectivement je suis là pour porter la
voix du front national effectivement
pour deux les patriotes du jura et sans
problème s'il faut me présenter à
d'autres élections giraille avec plaisir
donc candidat à tout ce qui passe on
peut pas être candidat à tour faut pas
non plus exagérer mais la wii fait
effectivement l'opportunité se
présentait donc j'ai dit pourquoi pas je
me présente effectivement en cas
d'élection vous vous avez préparé votre
succession à la mairie
ça se fera en temps et en heure ça c'est
sûr comme monsieur serre mais je
resterai de mon conseil municipal
c'est une petite bourgade dont j'ai fait
beaucoup de travail dessus j'ai beaucoup
de gros dossiers et hors de question que
je laisse tomber ma commune donc je
resterai dans le conseil municipal pour
continuer à oeuvrer ça c'est une
certitude
on continue paul-henri barre je me
tourne vers vous maintenant je les dis
en vous présentant vous êtes issu des
rangs du modem
lorsque votre investiture a été dévoilée
pour la république en marche il y a eu
quelques grincements de dents parmi les
marcheurs est ce à dire que vous
n'incarnez peut-être pas aux yeux de
tous le renouveau qu'appelle de ses
voeux emmanuel macron notre très
clairement qu'il ya eu effectivement un
peu de grincements auprès de marcheurs
je crois que c'était aussi léa à la
méthode de l'investiture où il ya eu
beaucoup d'espérance est forcément un
peu de frustration mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui des choses sont très
claires
les trois comités en marge du bassin
dolois sont derrière moi
ils travaillent tous les jours et y a
vraiment aucun souci de ce côté-là je
vous ai lu dans dans vos déclarations
d'intention mais ma priorité c'est la
moralisation mais également l'équilibré
entre la liberté
le social sur le territoire c'est ça qui
vous mène c'est ça le le renouveau de la
politique telle que vous voulez
l'incarner alors oui tout à fait manger
je me suis retrouvé dans prendre des
manuels macron sur ces deux axes de la
liberté de la solidarité protéger les
plus faibles
et puis en même temps donner des noms et
de la possibilité à ceux qui ont envie
d'avancer
donc c'est ce qui m'importe c'est ce qui
fait l'adn des manuels macro aida
politique de la république en marche
et je me suis complètement retrouvé
devant vous vous revendiquez du centre
droit vous avez été candidat modem
notamment aux élections européennes que
répondez vous à ceux qui considèrent
qu'en marché une simple entreprise de
recyclage des élus socialistes alors la
preuve en est que je n'en suis pas ni
examen plutôt une exception en franche
comté on va dire ni élu ni socialiste
marqués mais je crois que en marché et
un regroupement de gens qui veulent
avancer ensemble on a on a démoli des
barrières on y as envie vraiment envie
de faire quelque chose ensemble et c'est
pas les étiquettes politiques qui nous
marque
jean-bernard marcuse et la france
insoumise donc et encore une fois face à
un candidat de la france un saut mise un
candidat ou une candidate en
l'occurrence du parti communiste
français soumise peut-elle gagner tout
seul
le problème ne se pose pas de savoir
c'est françaises soumises peut gagner
tout seul alors roblet moi personne ne
va et france insoumise et pourquoi vous
n'arrivez pas à trouver d'allier
pourquoi personne ne va les français
soumise et on trouve pradalier s'il y a
des gens qui sont du akkar france est
soumise
si nous avons trouvé des alliés nous
avons sur l'ensemble du territoire des
candidats issus des rangs du parti
communiste y suit les rangs du parti
socialiste issu des rangs d'écologie les
verts donc nous avons des candidats qui
ont compris cette démarche de de
dynamisation d'un nouveau mouvement
citoyen où le citoyen prend la parole
pour porter une politique qu'il a
construite c'est l'avenir en commun et à
partir de ce moment là cette dynamique
est là elle a fait ses preuves
puisqu'elle a fait 19 plus de 19% 19 60
% au niveau national et l afep lui
presque 21% sur le niveau de la
circonscription
donc elle a fait ses preuves donc
aujourd'hui nous disons c'est dynamique
qui passe au dessus des partis qui passe
au dessus de la tambouille
est-ce que vous aux producteurs les
électeurs c'est incompréhensible qui est
un candidat communiste un candidat
france insoumise dans cette
circonscription parce que tous les deux
vous sutil le même candidat à la
présidentielle nous soutenir le même
candidat à la présidentielle nous étions
peut-être fait pour avoir une dynamique
à la de la france insoumise sur cette
initiative
alors il y a eu des rencontres et elles
n'ont pas pu aboutir et bien soit
moi je sais où j'en suis aujourd'hui et
je pars l'esprit tranquille puisque je
sais que je vais pouvoir rassembler
tous les gens qui se sont retrouvés dans
la dynamique de jean-luc mélenchon
laurence bernier je vais vous poser la
question de façon taquine en insistant
sur ce que dit gerani mais tout de même
quand on quand on lit le programme de
jean bernard mercredi et est le vôtre
on voit dans le même vocabulaire en
urgence sociale écologie refondations
nécessaire de notre démocratie
alors je réitère cette question que pose
et jérémy pourquoi deux candidats ici
plutôt qu'un ou une seule baie en tout
cas moi aujourd'hui je suis là candidat
du rassemblement des forces de gauche et
de l'écologie
c'est à dire qu'on a réussi sur notre
circonscription à ce que plusieurs
candidats retirent leur candidature et
non seulement me soutiennent mais mène
campagne à mes côtés donc aujourd'hui by
a la possibilité de porter effectivement
cette alternative solidaire écologique
et citoyenne
alors je regrette que jean bernard ne
soit pas inscrit dans cette dynamique
bon maintenant c'est comme ça et je
crois que la question c'est d'aller de
l'avant
je pense qu'aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
d'être connue sur le territoire pour
avoir mené de grands combats avoir
rassemblé déjà des milliers de personnes
sur des questions comme la défense de
l'hôpital ou sur d'autres sujets comme
les transports publics et donc voilà
c'est là dessus que je m'appuie juste
une précision vous vous dites candidate
du rassemblement rassemblement pas tout
à fait sûr toute la circonscription vous
avez remarqué que le parti socialiste
document a appelé à voter en marche
en dix ans ce n'est pas une question de
personnes c'est que la candidature que
vous portez ne répond pas et je les cite
aux enjeux de la 3e circonscription vous
réagissez comme ans la rocade c'est une
question d'enjeu sur la troisième crise
est ainsi formulée en tout cas oui c'est
surtout des personnes qui dès le premier
tour des présidentielles avait soutenu m
emmanuel macron donc ils sont là même
donc dans la même logique
voilà on sait que dans le parti
socialiste c'est une partie qui qui a
soutenu emmanuel macron que j'ai envie
de dire que les gens de gauche me
soutiennent les socialistes de gauche
que ceux qui aiment merci laurence
bernier merci verdict
on va accueillir à votre pass frédéric
gimenez de l'as républicain
[Musique]
alors frédéric va s'installer il a
choisi un 13-1 thème pour vous
interroger très précis qui s'ancre dans
l'actualité de cette circonscription
avec une grève au long cours au sein
d'une maison de retraite médicalisée
frédéric nous en plus un bon jour déjà
alors effectivement je vous parlais d'un
conflit social
ornans depuis 63 jours des
aides-soignants de la maison de retraite
de foucherans l'ehpad de foucherans sont
en grève
elles dénoncent des conditions de
travail qu'elle ne supporte plus qu'ils
sont des cuisante et visiblement de leur
direction
rien ne vient pour l'instant seule la rs
à bouger qui finirait ce qu'ils
financent très largement la structure
ainsi que le département
alors ça pose plusieurs questions
qui dit conditions de travail épuisante
et pénible pour le personnel du service
minimum pour les résidents résidents
pour lesquels une chambre à l'ehpad
revient à 2500 euros
première question on est sur la question
de la firme vie dans la dignité
deuxième question cette structure étant
largement financé sur l'argent public
n'est-il pas nécessaire que les
politiques insistent agissent pour qu'on
sorte de ce conflit manière
satisfaisante pour tout le monde et
jusqu'à présent on observe un peu le
silence des politiques
je crois que monsieur montre les a voulu
les voir elles n'ont pas voulu le
recevoir
à vous de commencer
[Musique]
je vous remercie disons que oui
effectivement j'ai j'ai essayé de
prendre contact avec elle j'ai d'autres
contacts je vous rassure parce que je
connais des personnes qui ont travaillé
là bas qui hélas démissionner vu les
conditions de travail ça c'est loin
d'être simple
je vous rappelle qu'à motion ancien
syndicaliste donc je connais quand même
pas mal de ce genre de combat je pense
que la première chose sur lequel faudra
peut-être déjà qu'on assiste c'est
effectivement les conditions de travail
un jeu rappelle que les femmes qui
travaillent là bas quand elles font des
formations d'avoir trente minutes pour
s'occuper des gens aujourd'hui elles en
ont à peine 14 noja c'est déjà un signe
assez alarmant hélas est en ruine une
longue attente devaient laver une
personnelle et refaire son lit c'est ça
voilà donc vous imaginez bien que les
résidents comme dans beaucoup d'autres
résidences à mon grand regret en ce qu
on pourrait parler de ses lames on peut
parler d'autres il appelle souvent les
courants d'air donc c'est quand même
assez déplorable donc effectivement
c'est quelque chose qui coûte très très
cher comme vous l'avez si bien dit je
rappelle quand même que le minimum
vieillesse dans le jura c'est 700 euros
c'est quand même très très peu donc
c'est pas réellement un cadeau qu'on
peut faire à nos anciens je pense qu'il
est grand temps de revaloriser déjà la
première chose revaloriser ces pensions
faut quand même pas oublier que ces gens
là son pays aussi toute leur vie ce sont
quand même des gens qui sont sacrifiés
aussi pour notre pays
j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on les
abandonne donc ça je pense que c'est
important aussi de le lire et je pense
qu'il ya sûrement d'autres démarches a
lancé comme le maintien à domicile
quelque chose sur les conflits pour
sortir du conflit
bon je sais qu'ils sont un peu plus
proche de mes confrères
monsieur marcousis on va dire les choses
telles qu'elles vont vous les pauvres
non bah écoutez je ne peux pas leur en
vouloir
si comme moi quelqu'un qui les défendent
c'est déjà pas rien on a fait la cette
démarche là ma foi si on va laisser
faire nos confrères et si réellement ils
ont besoin d'être je viendrai grand
plaisir ça c'est sûr je laisserai jamais
quelqu'un sur le bord de la route
ce fermier les sortants je peux vous les
avez reçus oui d'abord je voudrais
penser à toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillent en direction des personnes
âgées les aides soignantes et
infirmières tout le monde médical et
leur dire combien je comprends leurs
difficultés et que je les salue et je
les félicite parce que franchement elles
font un boulot admirable chaque jour
dans toutes les maisons dans tous les
établissements qui reçoit des personnes
âgées et je crois que c'est important
pour notre société
après moi je les ai reçu deux fois où on
a parlé je pense franchement elle était
en parfaite confiance
j'ai eu le préfet sur cette question
j'ai eu une fois la directrice de
l'établissement j'ai eu plusieurs fois
le directeur général j'ai eu aussi le
directeur de la rs est ensemble et avec
les syndicats nous avons obtenu l'
embauche de deux aides soignantes une
financé par l'établissement une financé
par l' agence régionale de santé
parce qu'effectivement il manquait deux
personnes il y avait deux équipes le
matin et l'après midi de 8 personnes
il fallait passer à 9 céderait leurs
revendications principales donc ça c'est
déjà une première revendication
après il ya des revendications
salariales auquel maintenant il faut que
la direction puisse assurer donc la
réflexion et trouver des solutions
en tous les cas c'est très clair que
partout où c'est nécessaire
le député doit être sur le terrain c'est
ce que j'ai fait pour mettre de l'huile
dans les rouages et trouver une solution
à ce concours du reggae du chemin il
faut en sortir quand même pas ce que
c'est je crois vous aurez remarqué que
c'est pas le député qui est le directeur
de l'établissement
et c'est pas lui non plus n'a ministre
je ne m'en donnez moi ce que je peux
faire c'est faire en sorte que nous
puissions trouver ensemble une sortie ce
qu'ils sachent et qu'elle sache mais le
savent bien
parce qu'elles ont mon numéro de
téléphone portable et qu'elle m'appelle
parvient
jean bernard marck usines comme la
vierge et montre les effectivement j'ai
la chance d'être assez régulièrement et
laurence bernier également parce qu'il
faut noter le travail collectif qui a pu
être fait très régulièrement nous sommes
auprès de ces personnes qui sont dans la
souffrance par rapport à leur travail
mais qui font une bagarre elles la font
pas que pour elle cette bagarre il faut
il faut bien voir les choses il y à un
conflit aujourd'hui
et derrière il y a une politique
nationale par rapport à ce
fonctionnement sur laquelle il va
falloir que l'on se penche pour apporter
des réponses et des vraies réponses
donc aujourd'hui on est sur ce conflit
et vous dites qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire
moi je suis syndicaliste assez assez
actif et j'ai eu à gérer aussi des
conflits et on n'a jamais gérer les
conflits par des bilatérales
arrivé au moment où il faut absolument
que toutes les parties se retrouvent
avec chacune de lui la mettre dans les
engrenages pour qu'on arrive vers un
résultat avec peut-être quelques
embauches possible avec peut-être
quelques deniers à mettre dans le sur la
fiche de paye en mai ou juin
aussi en réfléchissant que c'est un
établissement les opalines de foucherans
qui a distribué en 2015 trois cent
trente mille euros de dividendes et là
on arrive sur la financiarisation de la
fin de vie sur des gens qui achètent des
lits pour pour avoir une certaine
rentabilité et notamment c'est assez mal
c'est assez marrant parce que c'est le
serpent qui se mord la queue
ce sont des fonds de pension qui placent
leur argent pour délit de retraités et
qui vont me mettre ces gens dans la
misère pour ensuite payer les retraités
donc on marche un peu sur la tête et ça
nous donne peut-être à réfléchir sur la
retraite par capitalisation que certains
nous ont promis je ne sais pas qui est
certain mais moi je défend fermement la
retraite par répartition parce que je
pense que c'est ce que l'on doit aux
plus démunis ou plus faibles et aux plus
modestes parce que la retraite entendre
parce que la retraite
effectivement par répartition c'est la
solidarité nationale qui datent
d'ailleurs de 1946 du conseil la
résistance ayant fait tourner la parole
vous êtes un peu en avance sur le temps
de parole jean marie service j'ai
demandé de vous taire un petit peu on va
laisser les autres parlent et paul-henri
barre s'il vous plaît ce souci aux zozos
palin et je rejoins tout à fait jean
bernard marck usées sur le sujet vous
avez tous d'accord non monsieur je crée
relais et relève d'une part de la
financiarisation de deux de ses maisons
de retraite
il relève aussi d'un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises moi je
rappelle quand même que l'on a créé des
ars et que les ars ont sont en train de
conduire
je présente ars agences régionales de
santé c'est en quelque sorte le bras
armé de l'état pour gérer toutes les
problématiques santé en région et ceux
présentant du gouvernemental et crs nous
conduisent en ce moment dans le mur sur
la vieillesse mais sur le système de
santé de manière générale et je vais
faire plaisir à jean marie sermier
françois fillon avait annoncé qu'il
fallait réformer et reste dans son
propre je pense qu'il avait vraiment
réseau il faut remettre les helvètes
vraiment un candidat macron vous êtes
excusés mans vous êtes d'accord exemple
examiner avec jean-bernard marché je
sais que je rassemble plus largement
présente ses mocassins vernis s'il vous
plaît à la première chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que la question de
la perte d'autonomie est un des grands
chantiers de la période à venir
donc je parlerai pas de dépendance mais
de cette notion de perte d'autonomie qui
permet de plus axé l'action sur les
questions de solidarité
la deuxième chose sur le conflit des
opalines moi je l' ai découvert le 30
mars juste avant qu'elles se mettent en
grève au moment où j'étais au conseil de
surveillance avec des salariés de
l'hôpital et la population pour demander
le rétablissement de la ligne de smur de
l'hôpital pasteur et où je m'en vais
d'ailleurs ces problématiques si mais je
vendais chez servier depuis
moment a décidé d'ailleurs de supprimer
et donc je demande à monsieur fermiers
de faire voter le conseil de
surveillance pour ce maintien et donc
les salariés des opalines annoncé leur
grève et expliquer les raisons de leur
conflit alors maintenant je voudrais
mettre l'accent sur deux questions la
première chose c'est que l'établissement
a manqué au respect d'un certain nombre
de réglementations qui se traduisent par
de la maltraitance pour les résidents
pour les personnes qui sont dans cet
établissement en rescision eu des
plaintes depuis à une élite de fatima me
alao la direction mais on va pas se
faire la justice ici voilà d'accord mais
quand il ya une situation de
maltraitance des résidents et il ya une
gestion de ce conflit par la direction
qui et je dirai lamentable et donc pour
ce qui me concerne j'ai appelé la rs à
intervenir dans ce dans cette dans ce
conflit en demandant la mise sous
tutelle ou je dirais sous administration
provisoire de cet établissement qui est
un établissement à but lucratif privé
alors que l'ensemble des personnels
soignants sont financées par nos impôts
donc aujourd'hui pour sortir de ce
conflit puisque c'était votre question
eh bien il faut que les pouvoirs publics
prennent leur responsabilité merci
laurence bernier merci frédéric pour ce
thème qui concerne évidemment beaucoup
de monde tout de suite on retrouve
véronique
[Musique]
allez véronique vous exercer votre droit
de suite à qui vous avez envie de
demander des précisions par rapport à ce
qui a été dit dans les dernières minutes
d'abord à jean bernard marck usi vous
n'êtes pas le seul candidat ici à vous
indigner de ce que vous appelez la
financiarisation de la dépendance c'est
trivial mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on investit dans la dépendance
vieillesse comme on avait tiré dans tout
autre domaine lucratif si demain vous
êtes législateur imaginons vous avez une
majorité à l'assemblée france insoumise
vous décider quoi d'interdire confinance
yaris ce domaine si vous avez bien pris
le programme l'avenir en commun de la
france a soumises
vous avez dû voir que nous souhaitons
revenir que ce soit pour les soins sur
une prise en charge totale des dépenses
de santé pour les pour les patients mais
également pour tout ce qui est de
l'accompagnement pour aller vers un
service public nous ne sommes pas pour
la privatisation de l'hôpital comme s'
est en train de s'engager aujourd'hui
l'hôpital de dole aujourd'hui est en
train de mettre en oeuvre une
privatisation voisine avec la clinique
qui va venir se coller sur l'hôpital ce
n'est pas notre démarche
donc automatiquement c'est vrai que nous
allons lutter contre ces contre ces
cartels qui font de la fin de vie en
marche et ça c'est tout au public vous
vous interdisez au privé de s'occuper de
ces questions là c'est trivialement
comment on fait mais très très très très
honnêtement est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'il est acceptable que l'on fasse du
bénéfice à tel niveau sur le dos des
anciens se laisser des gens aujourd'hui
ils ont une grande fierté
ils ont laissé à leurs enfants une
société en meilleur état que celles
qu'ils avaient récupéré de leurs parents
aujourd'hui nous tous autour de la table
est ce qu'on pourra en dire autant je
n'en suis pas sûr donc il faut
absolument que le le les pouvoirs
publics prennent la main sur ces
problèmes là pour pouvoir orienter
véritablement la politique vers plus de
justice et la casse la capacité pour
tous les tous les aînés d'avoir le même
service
paris march m'adresse à vous en
rebondissant sur ce qu'on évoquait à
l'instant la question pourquoi pas mais
de remettre dans le giron public la
prise en charge de la dépendance je vous
ai entendu être d'accord tout à l'heure
avec macro avec clients
pourquoi pas avec un homme dont on ne
parle plus du tout depuis qu'il a perdu
la primaire socialiste vincent peillon
il avait proposé un service de maisons
de retraite publiques bonne ou mauvaise
idée
alors contraint à jean bernard marck
usées pour répondre à votre question je
crois qu'on ne peut pas tout enlever au
privé et comme on peut pas tout mettre
au public mais le politique est là pour
faire respecter des règles et pour
éviter les dérives notamment les dérives
financières
le service public pour les maisons de
retraite peut aussi s'articuler au
travers d'expériences qu'on est en train
que par exemple un panier le maire de
pagne est en train de mener sur des
maisons pour résidence ignore où le coût
serait deux fois et demie inférieur pour
accueillir des personnes dans des
conditions tout à fait acceptable je
crois qu'il faut être pragmatique et moi
j'apprécie beaucoup et mener maintenant
pour ça
le pragmatisme sait faire que privés ne
dépasse pas la ligne rouge et faire que
le public ait toute sa place quand il ne
devrait pas en compte le privé ne
répondent que vous mettiez d'intérieur
en cause de la politique actuelle de l'
agence régionale de santé
vers quoi doit-elle tendre selon vous
mais c'est pas la peau les politiques
actuelles c'est avant tout qu'ils
décident à la rs et qui pose réellement
les bases de notre système de santé
ce sont aujourd'hui des gens du
ministère de 1 hors de toute personne
politique il faut absolument et je le
redis françois fillon d il faut remettre
les patients les organisations de
patients les organisations médecins et
les politiques à la rs pour répondre aux
besoins du territoire jean marie servir
à faire vite car vous êtes un petit peu
avance en avance sur le temps de parole
néanmoins je vous ai entendu tout à leur
dire que vous étiez attachés à la
retraite par répartition vous pointer la
faiblesse des pensions et la cherté des
maisons de retraite des ehpad vous êtes
aussi le même élu qui souhaitait réduire
les charges notamment patronales mais
dans cette fameuse charge
il ya aussi toute la prévoyance ya la
maladie à la retraite comment est ce que
vous allez résoudre cette équation
baisser des charges et à voir les uhlans
vida qui dit qu'il faut assurer le
financement du cinquième risque c'est le
président jacques chirac avait dit qu'il
fallait et ce serait un honneur pour la
république de financer la dépendance
parce que notre nation oui on n'a pas
fait on l'a pas fait et bien moi je me
battrai pour qu'on puisse assurer le
financement du cinquième risque de la
dépendance parce que c'est ce que l'on
doit
nous est né lorsque vous savez qu'il ya
des tas de possibilités de faire des
économies sur le social kiné qui est
absolument inutile actuellement il ya du
social positif il ya du social qui est
du laxisme
il ya du social qui est en fait tout
simplement de l'assistanat et je crois
qu'il faut supprimer l'assistanat et
permettre à nos anciens de pouvoir avoir
le financement de leur dépendance
on arrive au terme déjà de ce débat je
vais vous donner 45 secondes à chacun
mais je vais vous donner la parole et si
vous avez pu que vous avez pu dire
quelques talents je vais vous donner la
parole laurence bernier votre conclusion
souplet 45 secondes pour convaincre les
uns les autres les électeurs de cette 3e
circonscription du jura vous avez
l'honneur à voulez bien
alors ben j'ai envie je veux être la
députée du bien commun c'est à dire
celle qui va défendre au quotidien les
services publics parce que des fonds de
la ruralité c'est permettre de garder du
service public de l'hôpital et pas
accepté leur démantèlement de permettre
que ont créé un vrai pôle public de
l'autonomie et avec des unités
territoriales de santé départementale
donc plus proche des services
et puis également et bien défendre là
les écoles les services de la poste
l'ensemble des services utiles aux
citoyens au quotidien et donc ça passe
bien par une politique sociale
écologique et aussi démocratique
merci laurence bernier jean bernard marc
cuisine bien moi plus d'abord je
voudrais rappeler qu'on est dans une
élection nationale et qu'à ce titre il
faut se méfier des campagnes de clocher
qui voudraient tout ramener au niveau
local alors je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
face au bloc libéral qui se dessine qui
va du ps jusqu'au républicain face à la
politique destructrice libéral de
monsieur macron face à la case des
droits sociaux on a besoin d'avoir une
force vive capable d'apporter au peuple
français de l'espoir pour avoir une
politique humaniste une politique
solidaire une politique sociale et ça on
le retrouve dans notre programme
l'avenir en commun alors
si dommage je suis l'élu de la 3e
circonscription je serai un élu utile un
élu qui ne cumulent pas les mandats qui
sera à l'écouté des citoyens et je
porterai l'espoir pour que d'homère
reviennent des jours meilleurs
merci jean bernard marck usine alors eh
ben moi j'ai décidé de servir mon pays
en étant député je veux servir tous les
électeurs de la circonscription pas se
dévide pas ceux des chambres tous
il faut qu'on se réunissent pour
reconstruire ce pays pour redonner dans
notre circonscription est à 46 % de gens
en colère
mon adversaire c'est la colère et la
désespérance des personnes j'espère
mettre en oeuvre le prendre des meuniers
de macron redonner du souffle et
d'espérance dans ce pays et puis être un
député à temps complet qui agit au
quotidien pour le bien-être de ses
concitoyens
merci paul henri barre stéphane
montrelais merci mes couteaux
conclusions effectivement je crois que
c'est marcousis va être une bonne
réflexion effectivement s'il s'agit bien
élections nationales donc je pense que
le mal est bien plus profond que ça on
pourrait rappeler les premières
prérogatives de l'état qui consiste à
protéger ses concitoyens
aujourd'hui c'est nous on aime bien eu
un bon débat sur ce sujet là mais il ya
bien d'autres ont préparé la plupart
police la justice et on est encore donc
effectivement je me présente à cette
élection pour porter la voix des
patriotes à l'assemblée nationale et
faire mettre en place le programme de
marine le pen quand il est grand temps
que cela change ça fait quand même
plusieurs décennies que nous subissons
la catastrophe de l'ump et du ps qui ne
sera qu'une accélération avec le
programme de monsieur macron mais
résiste étant d'avoir un changement
montrelais pour terminer ce dernier tour
de table
jean marie sermier oui je crois que les
jurassiens ont besoin d'un député qui
n'est pas sectaire députés qui les
écoutent un député qui est proche d'eux
un député qui est fort à l'assemblée
nationale qui peut faire entendre la
voix de notre 3e circonscriptions un
député qui rassemble largement au delà
de tous les courants et qui a des
convictions pour faire ensemble que
notre circonscription existe au niveau
national merci à vous je rappelle que
sont également candidats sur cette
troisième circonscription du jura
véronique henry ali kurt dominique revoy
et sylvie
viard tout de suite un nouveau débat on
part dans le doubs